mentioned that the staff gets on him
when he's not doing it right and when
asked about his return to the court he
said look if it were up to me I'd be out
there already but I trust the
organization and how they're handling
mangrum's
vaccine for New Orleans here's Williams
the attack signs Ingram in the corner
this Pelican team nice baseline drive
and look who's there shot ready to go
Brandon Ingram knocks it down that good
defensive play right there by Derrick
Favors favors has made a big difference
for this pelicans team at Ingram cans
another three
what a play right there behind some
Armory behind
and transition on a tough defender but
guess what right back at you was Brandon
England for three two for one
opportunity Ingram will pull and hit
from three finished three of the game
four frames and Ingram he has 25 merry
Christmas to you and yours
hope you're having a wonderful holiday
season Brandon Ingram he's certainly
having a nice Christmas 25 points
through three quarters his pelicans
sleep really played well on the
defensive end tonight
it can shots as well another this would
be their fifth but Dungey three or four
this road trip exactly they moved the
ball to break and Brendan is a bona fide
star he's got 30